Abby I feel like every healthy cookie
just tastes like are you able to make me
one that actually tastes good you know
me I am
all sugar sweets
make these no-bake peanut butter coconut
cookies and you are basically one of my
kids Brody I've got some coconut oil and
some peanut butter that is making quite
the mess we're just gonna pop this into
the microwave for 30 seconds give it a
good stir throw in a splash of vanilla
and mix everything together you're
looking for like a grainy sand like
texture we'll call it then I'm going to
just pop it onto a parchment sheet and
most importantly they still have to be
fun and taste great so obviously we're
adding a little drizzle of some dark
chocolate and some sprinkles because
sprinkles makes everything more fun I'm
just going to pop these into the freezer
for 20 minutes to let them set up these
are packed with fiber protein and
healthy fats from all the nut butter and
coconut and of course we've got a
healthy dose of fun
Brody you've gotta try these